perfect
not pretty
holy [ __ ] that's the only thing I could
think of to start with so a little
background before we start looking over
this in detail maybe a week or two ago I
got a comment on one of my spider-man
game retrospectives asking me if I had
heard rumors of B NOx losing the
spider-man rights to a developer known
as sucker punch Sucker Punch made
PlayStation exclusive games about
superheroes doing superhero II things
and I immediately thought that would be
great some of the hints were that a
stuntman who works for blur Studios
named Steven o Jung put on his resume
that he worked on performance capture
for an untitled ps4 spider-man game part
of that I remember someone say that a
sucker punch employee let out a tweet
saying their new project was something
spectacular little did we all know that
the rumors were half right yes the game
is a ps4 exclusive no it's not the
infamous devs
it was the developers of resistance
which I am equally excited for because I
actually really like that series yes
those games are shooters but they also
created sunset overdrive which is a
pretty cool third-person action game and
they did racquet and crank and even
Cyril the dragon so they have a good
resume of games so far I trust them as
much as Harvey Dent Phoenix gave up
midway through their time with the
license in the last great spider-man
game was from 2011 and after five years
of mediocrity and disappointment we get
this normally I don't want to jump on a
hype bandwagon but all the sadness with
Siegfried and Roy over there has led me
to being pretty excited for this now
let's talk about spider-man himself for
starters because I think I'm not
overstepping a boundary to say that
that's the most important part of this I
could be wrong just putting that out
there but he sounds a lot like older Ben
10 people see me and think they're safer
but it's not really me there see so I'll
assume he's being played by Yuri
Lowenthal which i think is a great
decision because if we can't have Josh
Keaton then we can have the next best
thing and thank God it isn't Drake the
coolest cool guy Bell Yuri is great at
moding and playing young characters and
I think he's done the voice before and
[ __ ] people don't care about so that
gets a pass wait he's also the main
character and sunset overdrive so now
I'm really sure it's him as long as he's
written well he's got my vote now let's
get to the thing that has a few people
up in arms you know exactly what it is
so what's the problem it's the amazing
spider-man suit with a civil war mask
with the squinty eyes the black suit
logo slapped onto it and some fingerless
white gloves on his gloves everyone's
first reaction to it is Wow I think the
ten-year-old version of myself has
absolutely beside himself upset but
17-year old me is saying yeah it's fine
I'm old enough to understand why they
wanted it to look different so far it
doesn't look like this game takes place
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe as well
it absolutely shouldn't because of the
lore problems that entails and we have
to distinguish it from the last game so
it can't look like Tong and it can't
look like Andrew and both of those suits
are pretty conservative designs all
things considered one is modern
spider-man and the other 70s spider-man
so what do we do to make it stand out
and get the point across well stir it up
and make it look weird and modern but
also familiar I don't think people are
wrong for disliking it I just don't
think it's worth getting too angry over
it reminds me most of the Ben Riley suit
design just with a white logo I look at
it from the perspective of Batman
costumes there are a million of those
and I don't get angry when it looks
different the suit and Arkham Knight
didn't look like the comics but it was
still an OK design plus this is a
superhero game there will be like a
thousand alternate costumes in DLC packs
so just pick one of those well here's
the part where I may embarrass myself by
being wrong or look like a huge cool guy
if I'm correct so fingers crossed I
guess I think that there actually is
gameplay in this trailer yes there's
stuff that's obviously a CGI
scene but other stuff looks a lot like
video games so you kind of have to play
spot the difference
that's a cutscene that's gameplay that's
a cutscene that's gameplay that's a
cutscene that's a very scripted gameplay
sequence that you won't control that's a
cutscene
that's another scripted gameplay
sequence and so far from what I can tell
it reminds me of what it would look like
if uncharted was about spider-man in
terms of graphics there are tons of
details in the environments this city is
gorgeous and packed with cars and
pedestrians and little things that make
it look like we've never seen before and
the gameplay looks very well animated
I'd compare with the console version
Batman Arkham Knight in terms of looks
it seems very polished and I like that
they put a lot of time into it I
especially love this sparkly effect on
the wet pavement so it looks like it
rained earlier today speaking of all of
this takes place in the same time of day
because from what I can tell this entire
demo seems to be clips from a single
action sequence that's probably near the
beginning of the game which is why he's
fighting guys with guns instead of a
super villain you got to build up to the
crazy stuff I like that because we're
not spoiling the whole game and the
trailer but we're showing enough to get
people excited that way when they
announced the main villain later
everyone will go nuts and the hype train
can keep on chugging spider-man is
finally back with Marvel in the movies
the new game looks fantastic he's not
possessed by Doc Ock anymore in the
comics I'd say for the moment the future
of spider-man is looking pretty good
right about now but we still can't
ignore the dark days we need closure I
have one more to talk about just one
more for now though I say we can all be
pretty optimistic well except for the
Xbox and PC players let's have a moment
of silence for those who don't own more
than one platform and love spider-man
your sacrifices will not be forgotten
you're all heroes in your own right
Godspeed you poor souls all right back
to reviewing a 19 year old cartoon if
you can guess what it is in the comments
you get a cookie and a shout-out in that
review hey way what's the actual title
is it really just spider-man ps4 or is
it just spider-man
you know what just call it spider-man
prom or spider-man Winter Formal